si tenemos un rectángulo con una base de
longitud b y una altura h
sabemos cómo calcular su área su área va
a ser igual a la base multiplicada por
la altura este es un repaso de cómo
calcular el área de un rectángulo se
multiplica la base por la altura ahora
veamos este paralelogramo en este
paralelogramo nuestra base sigue
teniendo una longitud b y seguimos
teniendo una altura h hablamos de la
altura no de la longitud de estos lados
que al menos como los he dibujado pues
están en diagonal la altura se calcula
si estoy de este lado hacia arriba y
bajó directamente hacia el siguiente
lado con un ángulo de 90 grados un
ángulo perpendicular a este lado y
cuando llegamos a este otro lado esta va
a ser nuestra altura en una situación
así en donde tenemos un paralelogramo y
conocemos su base y su altura
será su área al principio podríamos
decir bueno esto no es tan obvio como en
el rectángulo pero podemos hacer alguna
visualización que nos puede ayudar a
encontrar más fácil el área lo que voy a
hacer es tomar un pedazo del área que se
encuentra a la izquierda de la figura
ese triángulo que nos ayudó a hacer el
paralelogramo y lo voy a mover a la
derecha
y veremos algo bastante interesante así
que voy a tomar este pedazo de acá y lo
voy a mover hacia la derecha
y aquí seguimos teniendo el mismo
paralelogramo pero estoy moviendo esta
parte de su área a este otro lado
y qué es lo que acaba de pasar
noten que luce igualito que el
rectángulo anterior y esto pasó con solo
quitar un pedazo del área que estaba a
la izquierda y colocándola a la derecha
he reconstruido este rectángulo
reacomodando algunas partes del
paralelogramo y vemos que tienen la
misma área el área de este paralelogramo
o lo que solía ser el paralelogramo
antes de como viera este triángulo de
izquierda a derecha es la misma área que
el rectángulo de arriba su área es la
base por la altura es lo mismo
simplemente tome este pedazo de área que
se encontraba aquí a la izquierda y la
móvil la traslade para dejarla de este
lado el área no ha cambiado por lo que
el área de un paralelogramo vamos a
dejarlo como estaba
el área del paralelogramo si conocemos
la base y la altura también va a ser
igual a la multiplicación de la base por
la altura el área en ambos es base por
altura